il a fait un malheur à rio au côté de
hugh sinbo j'entends la conversation
trois médailles olympiques pour andré
degrâce
il se dirigeait tout droit vers un
premier titre mondial en 2017
mais il a raté sa dernière chance de
battre bolt à cause d'une blessure à la
cuisse droite
non je vais m'en chante bien votre un an
plus tard aux championnats canadiens
la même blessure interrompt sa saison
andré degrâce lave où il a péché par
impatience l'avis d'andré de grâce a
bien changé depuis la venue de bébé
gorille en juin dernier lui sa compagne
américaine médaillée olympique ni à ali
se sont installés en floride pour
travailler avec un nouvel entraîneur
winona ryder c'est qu'il avait perdu
confiance en son mentor street meknès
mais son début de saison au 200 m est
encourageant en fait depuis le départ du
roi votre ils sont plusieurs à prétendre
au trône
[Musique]
plusieurs à y croire comme son
compatriote eric brown
c'est lui qui a remplacé de grâce comme
l'homme le plus rapide au pays titre
qu'il avait décroché pour la première
fois cinq ans plus tôt photo succès iman
al banna astuces
on a fait du millage depuis ses malheurs
des derniers mondiaux à londres
le torontois croyait bien l'avoir obtenu
sa place en demi-finales du 200 m
lorsqu'il a été disqualifié pour avoir
touché à la ligne du virage
cette douleur est vite devenu son
carburant au final nous in more dennis
brown a terminé 4e du 200 mètres de la
grande finale du circuit d'amleague l'an
dernier aussi bien dire quatrième au
monde
il a ouvert la saison avec le même élan
prenant la troisième place à doigt
convaincue qu'il al'étoffe d'un champion
du monde
[Musique]
andré degrâce veut revenir plus fort et
ne craint pas les obstacles et se promet
une chose dans le processus ne pas aller
trop vite
beau défi pour un sprinteur c'est diane
souris radio canada montréal